hydro québec dévoilé son plan
stratégique 2020 2024 deux grands
objectifs développer l'économie du
québec et améliorer le bénéfice net et
quatre priorités électrifier les
transports et convertir les systèmes qui
sont aux énergies fossiles actuellement
accroître les exportations faire des
acquisitions à l'étranger prendre des
participations au québec achevé la
romaine 4 améliorer le service à la
clientèle et la fiabilité du réseau
électrique accroître l'efficience et la
productivité d'hydro-québec
hydro-québec évoque le développement de
l'hydrogène l'éolien le solaire et dit
vouloir prendre une décision concernant
de futurs projets c'est un plan qui est
dans la continuité c'est un plan
responsable qu'on vient de livrer alors
on a été un peu comme c'est ce que j'ai
parlé du contrat du massachusetts qui
est un conte extrêmement important pour
nous mais c'est clair qu'on continue des
équipes solides ce plancher puis et je
les dis aussi tantôt on est extrêmement
patient en affaires la plus grande
qualité c'est d'être patient analyse du
plan stratégique avec le professeur
normand mousseau bonsoir normes amoussou
mois vous avez donc regarder ce plan
stratégique vous avez assisté aussi à la
conférence de monsieur martel ce midi à
montréal
qu'est ce que vous en pensez en fait
j'aimerais c'est un clan qui couvre en
faisant on ne sait pas de quoi sera fait
l'avenir et les prochaines années vont
surtout servir à explorer des
possibilités c'est mentionné l'hydrogène
on va explorer la possibilité de faire
de la domotique avec le louvre nouveau
les compagnies low on va donc regarder
voir qu'est-ce qui peut être payant et
où est ce qu'on s'en va et en gros c'est
un gros point d'interrogation qu'on a
dans le clan fera tegick un gros point
d'interrogation mais quand même un
chiffre puis on va le voir dans le
graphique qui sort de du plan
stratégique aujourd'hui le désir
d'atteindre une rentabilité grandissant
en ce moment le bénéfice net est de 2
milliards 800 millions mais en 2030 on
veut se rendre à 5 milliards 200
millions
est-ce qu'on explique comment on sera là
en gros on nous dit pas vraiment comment
refaire l'augmentation annuelle mais on
peut imaginer avec entre autres
l'augmentation des tarifs et mais le
gros saut en bad
1022 c'est avec le contrat avec boston
ici donc de 3 milliards 100 millions à 3
milliards sera donc le contrat du
massachusetts tombé sur leur maison sur
cette voie là le gros problème c'est
évidemment c'est que c'est loin d'être
acquis
il ya beaucoup de contestations mais on
pensait que ça allait passer
relativement facilement l'avionneur a
approuvé et le une contestation sur le
terrain
il devrait avoir un référendum qui soit
a tenu le sait pas encore complètement
assurés mais ça risque d'aller vers la
et les saveurs d'ici et draw québec
qu'on ne se le dit sur ce type de gros
projets vers les états unis
voilà mais on a vu lille c'est pas
facile de construire des lignes de
transport il ya beaucoup de positions et
derrière il ya les groupes
environnementaux mais aussi derrière
tous ceux qui voudraient vendre
l'électricité à la place au québec les
gaz air et autres qui sont aussi dans le
portrait de position je vais prendre
quelques points qu'on retrouve plus
précis si on veut donc la stratégie que
vous demandez de commenter
on parle beaucoup de d'électrification
des transports de conversion de
l'économie à l'électricité est ce que
c'est ambitieux de ce côté là on n'a pas
de chiffres dont on ne sait pas cette
ambition ou non mais ça se sent laissa
sa ligne avec le pecq le nouveau plan du
gouvernement pour les changements
climatique d'ici 2030 qui vont payer les
nord dans les bars depuis quelques temps
et c'est le plan pour les changements
électrification changement climatique
sur voilà et qui va certainement pousser
beaucoup vers l'électrification donc
hydro-québec en préparation avec ça dit
on va appuyer nous ces efforts
d'électrification de toute l'économie du
québec incluant l'industrie bâtiment
transport 1600 nouvelles bornes de
recharge rapide d'ici 2030 dans le
circuit électrique
oui donc on augmente de manière
importante on voit l'importance de des
bornes de recharge rapide pour
simplement des bonnes grande désarmés
qui vont rapidement et moi je sens que
ça va être installé avant 2030 avec le
transport électrique qui de plus en plus
courant donc ça risque de se faire plus
rapidement que que lentement
est-ce que la stratégie internationale
d'hydro-québec qui porte sur
l'exportation les acquisitions à
l'étranger fonctionne on a vu ça va être
très difficile de faire des acquisitions
n'ont ils pas eu beaucoup d'acquis
s'ils ont beaucoup de difficulté à
signer des contrats long terme donc
présentement on vend de l'électricité
beaucoup à nos partenaires mais ce sont
des cris qu'on vend à la demande voilà
on n'a pas de contrat à long terme ou
peu et si on va au ciné c'est vrai en
dise il est absolument
je pense que plus de chances qu'on
enseigne vers les maritimes par exemple
nouvelle écosse nouveau brunswick ayons
des enjeux de fermeture de centrales au
charbon et il ya plus de chance à mon
avis consigne de ce côté là que aux
états unis on signe mais la difficulté
va être de construire des lignes de
transport et on en a parlé
qui donc d'avoir l'acceptabilité sociale
ou est romandie on veut achever la rue
même 4
c'est dans l'ordre des choses sur les
futures un moment donné a aussi mis
monsieur legault parlait de grands
barrages supplémentaires
il est écrit dans le dans le plan
prendre une décision concernant de
futurs projets oui donc un fuseau projet
incluant les livres casse énergétique
solaire éolien ou l'hydroélectricité et
je pense que pour le sud du québec
il est très peu probable qu'on avait de
nouveaux grands barrages parce que pour
beaucoup de stockage disponible alors
pour d'électricité disponible je sais
quand au fil de l'eau par exemple il n'y
a pas davantage par rapport à l'éolien
ou le solaire qui sont moins chers donc
à mon avis on fera pas d'écran des
projets de barrages venez on veut
faciliter l'essor des énergies
renouvelables intermittentes comme
l'éolien le sol en autant qu'on est des
marchés présentement on a on est en
surproduction d'électricité au québec on
en vend beaucoup mais une bonne partie à
très faible coût alors pour le moment on
n'est pas dans une situation de
développé ces six nouveaux
approvisionnements la moins d'avoir une
demande payant quand on puisse
développer soutenir le développement
d'hydrogène oui ici à travers la planète
en fait on serait en réaliste peut-être
que les batteries seront pas suffisantes
pour stocker l'énergie donc l'hydrogène
ici c'est pas une source d'énergie
c'est un vecteur d'énergie on peut
emmagasiner l'hydrogène qu'on fait à
partir du méthane du gaz naturel ou à
partir de l'électricité et on peut
mettre dans des réservoirs et l'utiliser
quand on en a besoin
ou encore dans le transport leur pareil
et je pense ici on ne sait pas si ça va
être rentable un jour on ne sait pas
comment ça va être compétitif par
rapport aux autres technologies mais
faut être là on nous dit on a beaucoup
de réserves d'eau et ça c'est la grande
blague ça s'apprend pas beaucoup d'eau
pour faire de l'hydrogène tout le monde
de l'eau qu'il faut pour l'hydrogène de
problème c'est l'énergie
on a de l'électricité ici donc peut-être
ça sera une source qu'on sera pas un
grand exportateur d une hydre aux jeunes
ça peut s'insérer dans notre demande
nous et est-ce qu'on doit compter sur le
tm4 le moteur tm 4 présentement on a
déjà hydro québec a vendu une partie de
tm4 adana qui est un grand fournisseur
de pièces américain et qui permet de
développer beaucoup le moteur je pense
pas que ça soit ça soit des revenus qui
vont combler les manques à gagner pour
hydro québec mais ça va contribuer au
développement ça va contribuer à asseoir
hydro-québec comme joueur important
manteau maintenant très intéressant
merci pour cette analyse normand
mousseau 5 0